hello and welcome back to game sports
coverage of e3 2015 i'm neesee james
taking over from Danny O'Dwyer here on
the stage with Mark Alexei the creative
director of Assassin's Creed syndicate
so mark Alexei let's talk about what
you're showing this year at e3 we saw
yesterday the Ubisoft press conference
we had a kind of Jacob sort of I better
look at him and then it's Sony you kind
of bust it out with Evie the other
protagonist what was it like to kind of
show the world these two these two
Assassin's well for me I'm very proud to
have shown Evie yesterday to have
revealed her to the world this is
something that's been really dear to me
and it's been core to the game that
we've been trying to build so I'm kind
of relieved to finally be able to talk
about both Jacob and Evie because the
story is very much about those two
characters and how they grow up out they
they evolve and and from their different
very different personalities yeah so
nice to be able to play with the Jew
allottee of the two characters like play
them off against each other because I
mean obviously they're gonna have that
sibling rivalry yeah absolutely and it's
exactly something that's in the game so
Jacob is more let's say more brash he
takes tackles situations head-on he
doesn't think too much and he always
does things with a smile he's someone
who enjoys very much what he's doing
Evie is more reserved she's more
strategic in her approach to things she
thinks things true and you can imagine
the clashes that we'll have between the
brother and the sister as the explore
this world of Victorian London so let's
let's talk about the twins themselves so
they come from Crawley yes and they
found their way into the the thick of it
in the big bad city of London yes they
were both born assassins and the things
are not things are not going very well
for the assassins in nineteen in the
19th century the Templars are firmly in
control of the Industrial Revolution
and the City of London itself so London
is kind of the center of the world at
that time it's one of the biggest cities
in the world it's the center of the
Industrial Revolution and one of the
things that we're doing differently this
year is that it the players are not
unravelling a strange mystery the game
the setup is laid out before them at the
start of the game the Templars are
firmly in control of London
you know the Templar Grandmaster is and
our two assassins decide by themselves
to go and destroy the hold that the
Templars have on the city so it makes
for a nice open playground an open
setting for our players to engage in so
it reminds me a little bit of the Borgia
influence in was it Brotherhood when you
know you know you know who the bad guys
are already and you go take them down
yeah one of the ways that you can do
that in syndicate is gang walls yeah
basically can you tell me a little bit
about this because we saw a little bit
in the gameplay trailer so one of the
things the ways that Jacob and Evie will
try to take back London is true the
street gangs so the Templars control the
street gang and through those gangs they
control the working-classes
so one of the ways Jacob and Evie will
fight back against the Templar is create
by creating their own gang and then from
borough to borough conquered the city
and expand the influence of their gang
and they're gonna be a super important
tool for the player in the game in the
sense that you'll be able to recruit and
power them up and they'll follow you
around so if you recruit for example
five five gang members and you up on a
vehicle because you can climb on any
vehicle that you want they'll hop on the
vehicle would you open the doors get in
but if there's not enough space they'll
hijack a vehicle of their own so you're
moving through the city with your own
gang so it feels really cool fresh and
different than what we've seen in the
past so you mentioned briefly vehicles
there and they have we're getting a very
big GTA vibe from that you know you just
go hijack it run some people over the
question I have so in Assassin's Creed
typically you can't kill civilians
you'll get desynchronized if you kill
civilian
what if say I'm trembling down the
street in a carriage that I've stolen
and I accidentally knock into someone
who's on the way to the bakery or
something you'll see that our civilians
are very good at dodging those cards so
they jump out of the way because I don't
think it would be fun for the players to
just be synchronized as they mow true -
true civilians so still we keep that
part of the franchise but we've done a
lot of efforts to make sure those
civilians move out of the way for the
player to have fun that is good to hear
no absolutely so the vehicles knew you
you're kind of reinventing the South a
little bit as well so we're very used to
this cover based hiding in the hay bales
what but you also bring back whistling
which is a great thing that I really
missed so he took me a little bit about
how you're reinventing the game that is
so well known for hiding in the shadows
so last year Assassin's Creed unity and
introduced a feature that was much
awaited by our fans the crouch so and
you could snap on on the corners of
buildings so what we're trying to do
differently this year is we keep trying
to improve the game so we're moving to a
soft snap instead of having a hard snap
so it's much more accessible and fluid
fluidity is really a key word for us
this year making the experience feel
more fluid for players but also giving
for me stealth is about manipulating the
environment so players have more tools
now than ever we're bringing back the
whistle but also we're trying to think
about our different tools can improve
stealth showing knives are a good
example so instead of just being used to
kill enemies you can throw them on the
wall and create a distraction so stealth
gameplay has a lot to do with how you
manipulate the environment and players
will have tools to do that this year so
we saw in the gameplay walkthrough as
well throwing a throwing knife and not
bringing down yongsan people so there's
gonna be a lot more of that as well a
lot more environmental usage for players
to enjoy and try to draw enemies with a
whistle under one of those things that
you can just throw a knife at and it
falls on the enemies and kills them so
let's talk about combat as well so the
Victorian era
that's when swordplay was kind of dying
out
you know you couldn't just carry around
a broadsword anymore so Eevee especially
has it came they sawed cane yeah so
she's kind of got festival it's the cane
sword historian says it's really really
important it's not a sword game it's a
cane sword so how are you kind of
basically like taking that into account
but still getting in some sort play so
it's an era more of concealed weapons
but it's an era of great innovations as
well for combat so our players will app
a revolver which is something that
really changes the way you approach
situations when you have a six-shooter I
mean there are many different ways you
can approach that situation obviously
but it's not a stealth weapon
so you'll attract a lot of attention if
you use it so there are counterbalance
to absolutely but in terms of weapons we
have rats knuckles we've got the kukri
knives that comes from from the far side
of the Empire and we've got the cane
sword
I almost said sword game but but one of
the things that changes about combat
this year that we're trying to change is
shifty the the opportunity to the player
to take the advantage take the offensive
so instead of staying and waiting for to
counter enemies this is not a winning
strategy you need to stun the enemies
because they'll attack at the same time
and it becomes much more of a fluid
dense in-between the enemies and we're
bringing back multi counters multi
finishers and all that to make the
combat more spectacular and enjoyable
how difficult is it to kind of make your
own mark on a franchise that is so well
it's revered it's loved and we have
these familias threads and strands in
each in each iteration how do you make a
mark on that well we've been working on
Assassin's Creed in the Quebec City
studio since Assassin's Creed
Brotherhood so we take a lot of
inspiration from that game it was really
for me one of the best ones and in the
franchise but we brought to it a spirit
of innovation we were working on the
Leonardo machines the war machines like
the flying machine the tank and all
those all those things so I was really
glad to have Bill dos for Brotherhood
and the studio brings you
sanskrit said to get this spirit of
innovation which is why we have the Rope
launcher which is incredible tool for
players to to climb on top of buildings
and zipline across the the environment
I've got carriages we've got all those
things bringing a second playable
character so I feel that this is out to
innovation and modernizing the
experience that we will leave our mark
on the franchise finally I think I have
to ask cuz I live there London it's a
great time period it's a great city I
mean what's it like kind of just you
know pouring more life into it for me
the more I look at London the more I
feel like we've had the abortion if you
to create one of the most iconic and
represent one of the most iconic cities
in the world with them the Thames in the
middle is just so incredible and it's
not something that we've shown yet
you'll have to stay tuned to see more of
it but it brings so much incredible life
into the city it's filled with boats
that I think will capture people's
imagination but it's also a city of
landmarks I mean people I know when I
scouted London to build the game I
couldn't get into Westminster Palace but
it's something that we can put in the
game and there's a good there's a
fantasy there to be able to go into the
halls of power other things like the the
the train stations which I think will
amaze people they were the cathedrals of
their era and there are just so many
things for people to explore and we've
had a lot of people from London come
work on the game with us
Lydia Andrew our audio director is was
born just across Charing Cross she she
put so much detail and attention to
making sure that every part of the city
feels different and it feels like her
home and finally maybe on London one of
the things that I love the most about
the city is how each part feels very
different so from Whitechapel that in
which will represent more the poverty of
the era to Westminster where you have
like the halls of power of politics
Buckingham with the royalty where you
feel that it's an empire you'll have the
South Shore which is something that's
completely different from what we see
today with all the industries so really
have a different story for to tell
players as they move through the
the city market makes me thank you so
much for joining me can't wait to play
more of Assassin's Creed syndicate when
it comes out later this year which
platforms what date so it's gonna come
out on October 23rd on ps4 Xbox one and
later in the fall on PC wonderful thank
you so much stay tuned here the games
would stage where we will be having well
next up it's an iconic franchise we're
gonna have some Star Fox zero make sure
you stay tuned